this is the very first time you got to
see the whole film in full how's it
gonna be if he what are you expecting
well I'm no comment only because I don't
want to I don't want to have any
expectations but I just know that I
welled up five seconds ago and and I'm
this is the press junkets so I don't
know to try and keep it together you
know we have to do a Q&A afterwards and
then we're gonna do a small performance
too so we have to you know try and maybe
hold back on some of the well we we saw
one cut a couple of months ago and the
both of us were in tears on the couch
you know within within minutes so
hopefully hopefully there's couches on
that yes actually hopefully and and but
but you know I want to also just watch
it from the from I can't separate myself
obviously but I'll be interesting to
watch it with people in there who don't
have necessarily a strong connection to
Kate McGarrigle really and you know I
think that that I think the oceans will
still come across I talking about the
connections the audience might have with
Kate McGarrigle let's talk a little bit
about what made her so special her music
the kind of life she lived I think I
think Kate and Anna we should say Kate
and Anna McGarrigle because they were
really one in the same in a lot of ways
they they had a very big international
career that they that they went out and
got but then at a certain point they
decided to focus on their on their
children and bring up their kids in
Canada and they didn't necessarily turn
their backs on show business we they
still do tours they still made albums
but it really became just one of the
facets of their very busy lives and and
not like the main thrust of it so they I
think in the end they might have not
they might have lost a lot of fame or
success or money and all of that but but
but their material remained so pure and
so real and so material II like and I
think that that that's so much that's
worth so much you know I'm so rare to
find these days
yes and what kind of inference that they
had on has she had on you both as
musicians not just as obviously as the
mother you know for me you know you as a
young person you make efforts to sort of
somehow be different because it was
always important to somehow sound
different especially for me growing up
being the youngest of a lot of people
who were writing songs and then you
realize such that that you can escape
you know and that and as I get older and
especially now that she's gone all I'm
trying to do is get back to the thing
that that makes me sound at all like her
yeah so I'm trying to pull that back get
that back and because I realized that
that's really the most valuable and the
same few rethus yeah I mean I've always
my mother and I were always we were
pretty tight for the whole for the whole
voyage and and I I know I know
everything I learned everything from her
she taught me everything I know and I
taught her a few things - that's
fantastic thank you so much guys
you